In this video, we
will see how we
can add a new variable
to our data frame.
Suppose that we want to add
a variable to our USDA data
frame that takes a value
1 if the food has higher
sodium than average,
and 0 if the food has
lower sodium than average.
Let's do this step by step.
To check if the first
food in the dataset
has a higher amount of sodium
compared to the average,
we can simply ask R to dig up
the first value in the Sodium
vector, using the square
brackets and the index 1.
And then compare it using
the greater-than sign
to the mean of
the Sodium vector,
and then do not forget to remove
the non-available entries.
And we obtain TRUE.
How about the 50th food?
Well, let's go back
using the Up arrow,
and simply change the index 1
to 50, and now we get FALSE.
This means that the first
food has higher sodium
content than average,
and the 50th food
has lower sodium
content than average.
Now, we can write
the same command,
but on all the vector Sodium.
Let's use the Up arrow, and
delete the square brackets
with the index 50.
But we know we have 7,000
foods, and we really
don't want to output
7,000 values right now.
So how about instead, we just
save the output to a vector,
and we're going to
call it HighSodium.
And now let's look at the
structure of the HighSodium
vector.
And then we see that the
HighSodium vector indeed
has all these values--
TRUE and FALSE--
which are called logicals.
So basically the type of the
HighSodium vector is logical.
But remember, we said we
wanted values 1's and 0's.
So instead of TRUE, we want 1.
And instead of FALSE,
we want a value of 0.
Well, to do this, we
need to change the data
type of HighSodium
to numeric, and we
can do this using the
as.numeric function.
So let's use the Up
arrow twice, and then
enclose this logical expression
by the as.numeric function.
So as.numeric, and now look up
the structure of HighSodium,
and now we see that we turned
it into a numerical vector with
values 0's and 1's.
Now, this vector,
HighSodium, is not
associated with the
USDA data frame.
How can we add a variable,
HighSodium, to our data frame?
Well, simply we need to
use the dollar notation.
So let's go back
twice to the command
where we created the
HighSodium vector,
and then simply right now,
instead of just calling
it HighSodium, we associate
it with the USDA data
frame using the dollar notation.
Now, pressing Enter, and going
and checking the structure
of the USDA data frame,
we see that we just added
the HighSodium variable
that was not present before,
and it's a numerical variable
with values 1's and 0's.
Now we can do the same, and
add the variables HighProtein,
HighCarbs, HighFat,
similarly to our data frame.
Well, let's do this
quickly using the Up arrow,
and then let's go and replace
Sodium now by Protein.
So again, here Sodium
is replaced by Protein.
And then we're going to call
this new variable HighProtein.
And do the same with TotalFat.
So instead of
Protein, we're going
to have TotalFat, and then
replace it here again,
and the variable name
is going to be HighFat.
And finally,
Carbohydrates-- so here
is the vector of Carbohydrates,
and this is, too,
getting the
Carbohydrates vector.
And finally, this last
variable that we want to add
is called HighCarbs.
And now looking at the structure
of the USDA data frame,
we see that we
successfully added
these three new variables, which
are high HighProtein, HighFat,
and HighCarbs, in
addition to the HighSodium
variable that we
added previously.
So how can we now
find relationships
between these variables, and
also the original variables
that we had in the
USDA data frame?
Well, we're going to
be using the table
and the tapply functions
in our next video.